welcome to the data modernization
mechanisms theory my name is lokesh kris
i'm a data management and data analytics
specialist at google cloud
i have several years of experience
working on large
public and private cloud deployments and
migrations i also had the opportunity to
start couple of companies in the past
or just advertising and every
technologies i'm a spiritualist
dad traveler i love reading books and
enjoy cooking well and free
the agenda for today is to understand
how large enterprises approach data
modernization
and solve some of their complex
challenges such as data modernization
reducing the cost
improving agility for business and
integration et cetera and move their
business forward progressively
microsoft is a large customer i work
with and we are going to be hearing from
them and how they are successfully
executing their data modernization
strategy on google cloud
why do enterprise modernize today
why are they looking at modernization
they increasingly
want to address latest business
opportunities
and they also want to leverage the
latest technology trends and
architectures and
the latest technologies available in the
cloud and they do so by adopting or
migrating to the cloud
and making cloud as part of the journey
and enterprises are increasingly looking
to modernize the business application
by moving to the cloud and why google
cloud why
what makes google cloud different we
deliver end-to-end
security solutions from the data center
all the way to the end user
with the purpose-built infrastructure
and security by default
we believe in open cloud and we have
designed google cloud to support
whatever system best
suits your needs and what and whether
hybrid or multi cloud or something in
between
we strive to make google cloud easy to
use automating manual
tasks and configuration wherever
possible so your teams can focus on
deployment and development
and less on managing infrastructure we
embed
intelligence in everything making it
easy for you to apply
ai and ml in your own organization
lastly we bring you the best of google
in our solutions
and we can help you create a more
innovative and collaborative culture in
your own organization
and with that i have great pleasure in
introducing
anshul kumar director of data analytics
and innovation
uh from meccasim thank you lukeish for
having me i'm
excited to share my experiences so far
and
the amount of work that location the
product teams have
helped us get through it so pretty cool
i my team focuses on the analytics that
powers our
b2b customer experiences what that means
is
all the analytics that's within our
e-commerce
platforms our value prop to our
customers is
we will give them access in addition to
the the healthcare products with
the right products at the right cost
we'll also give them access to analytics
which will help them
run a more uh optimized shop
and that's the piece that our team works
on
when i'm not working i am exploring
other open source
technology stacks dad and an inspiring
blogger
we have a quick one minute advocacy
video
hope you enjoy it it's 11 15 am
on a tuesday in the next minute
mckesson will make better health
possible for millions of people
at the same time a young girl in los
angeles
will start her road to recovery after
her primary care physician
used a rapid strep test we delivered to
make the right diagnosis
an aging tucson woman will move into an
affordable long-term care facility
that uses our inventory solutions to
control costs and improve patient care
a woman in paris receives personalized
treatment for her skin condition from
her local pharmacist
avoiding a trip to the dermatologist a
line of third graders in little rock
will head to the nurse's office for
needed flu shots we supply to their
local school district
a pharmacist in montreal reminds a
diabetes patient to take his medication
because a system we developed with
manufacturers triggered
an adherence consultation a single mom
in a rural area gets her critical
medication and stays on budget
because we supplied her local pharmacy
with a cost-effective generic
[Music]
this is the difference mckesson makes in
one minute
this is the difference we make every
minute
what will we make possible in the next
minute
the next hour the next year
it's now 11 16 am it's time to get back
to work
[Music]
and that was one minute at mckesson we
are in the healthcare distribution
business
mckesson has a rich history of selling
many different products and and some of
the brands that we see here on the slide
were
at some point on biomechanism founded in
1833 it's a fortune 7 company
80 000 strong headquarters in
edmond texas we do have a global
footprint we have
our business units in european union and
in canada
and especially during the cobit 19
i'm very proud to be part of team
mckesson our ceo
and device project here bridge at the
white house
and uh the magazine distribution
leadership team
and all our dc leaders and the folks and
special
shout out to them for helping out
getting the
product and the hot spots during wave
one in this talk we'll
start with the current state how we got
here we'll get into mckesson's way of
adopting cloud and it's a blend of org
structure
processes training resources will touch
upon
foundational things to have in place
before you start your cloud journey or
while you have your cloud journey we'll
talk about various patterns when you
think about detail storage
and end up the call with where i'll be
on this journey
so ancho what led you to choose google
cloud platform
can you could you please walk us through
some of the drivers is why google cloud
platform that is a good question
location
folks will have another a big long list
i'm sure
but uh personally for me the healthcare
apis that google cloud platform
offers out of the box those can be
a game changer our customers are
physicians office surgery centers
and hospitals so if we could leverage
these
apis to latch onto their erp systems and
do the point in time delivery of the
product when they need it
that's going to be fantastic we talked
about the
rich mckesson history and
should be no surprise that over time
there were multiple
mergers and acquisitions that took place
and
when you go through mergers and
acquisitions you also
bring in teams from different companies
with
it teams they bring in their own
technology stacks
so it should be no surprise to see
multiple
erp systems here multiple
edws and multiple applications in
databases
when i talk about multiple application
databases not just the
name of the database but also the flavor
if we have
jd adwords we have sap we have oracle
we have sql we have mysql and
and so on in addition we also have
multiple etl tools and
various ways to replicate information
there is a good opportunity for
standardization that should be the
takeaway
and we are a multi-cloud shop
gerson has access to microsoft azure
public cloud and google cloud and for
our crm we are a sales force
so we talked about earlier on multiple
teams getting together so
thousands of people you just giving them
keys to the public cloud
is not going to be a most effective way
for cloud adoption
and the senior leadership did
identify this and they decided to
adopt safe what is safe safe is
scale agile framework so this is agile
for enterprises
larger enterprises and there's tons of
good
information out there on the internet
you can search upon it
real quickly the different milestones or
phases that i've
highlighted here project was a senior
leadership
buy for the process yes safe is what we
are going to adopt
foundation is setting up of the internal
mckesson cloud team the internal
mckesson cloud team
is responsible for the connectivity to
gcp public cloud
all the cost related conversations all
the security related conversations
new feature enablement giving access to
app development teams such as myself
they do it all
and the third phase was migration
so migration could have could mean
different things to various people
for uh specifically for my group we had
some
applications which were running at
capacity
and we thought these are good candidates
right to be moved over to public cloud
from on-prem so that's what
we did we ended up hybrid uh migrating
those applications
small manageable sizes and the goal is
after 100 on public cloud
we just start building like native cloud
applications reduce our technical debt
and
app modernization just keep eyes open
for any opportunities for modernizing
as part of the medicine or gcp
adoption the maxim team got access to a
few
like free on-demand learning programs
uh these were instrumental for my team
and do
they pretty much acted like a slingshot
right folks could go in
and at the self-pace at their own
leisure learn the new technology stack
and next thing you know they're building
upon that
so i highly recommend checking this
feature out with your google account
executives
it's not just for the hands-on
developers there is some good content
out there
for leadership folks as well or
transformation and just a crowded option
so this one i would call the replication
strategy as a foundational piece and for
going to cloud
and why i'm calling it foundational is
we decided to go with a less complicated
workflow
into public cloud first and
not rule out our erp right day one erp
systems are the one which are running
our core business of big packet shipping
so we do not want to go with erp day one
into public cloud
instead we went with the analytical
workloads and the app
application the e-commerce workloads
into public cloud
and when you do that right the original
data
is going to initiate on your erp systems
so how do you compute on the cloud you
cannot compute on the cloud unless you
get that get that
enabled source information and this is
what
the context is for this slide it's good
to have a
at least think through how do you get
your
erp information the orders which are
getting generated day in day out
how do you make them available through
one single
structured flow into cloud and
from there the app development teams
which are many
can utilize the source data and run with
the apps
that they are closest to their own
subject matter expertise
and uh our vp would say that he would
often use the phrase 10 yard teams
who know how to run 10 yards but they
would not know how to score a touchdown
so you don't want to be in that
situation where multiple app development
teams are just
using their own method opening up
firewalls
between your on-prem data centers and
onto your
public cloud and all of them are
more than often right replicating the
same information
which can result into right different
problems like first is reduced
visibility for sure
you do not know what's being moved right
from on-prem to the cloud
and then the other one would be the
security team has limited visibility and
do
what is it is there patient information
that's flowing through
and if yes what are the controls in
place
so this one is a it's a real graph
database uh screenshot of just the
replications running within the oracle
databases
this is just dblink it does not cover
the other applications that we are using
outside of that oracle cluster this is
just a demonstrable cluster
the good thing here is this is all
constrained and it's on-prem
but imagine if this was the case for
connectivity
from on-prem to the public cloud you you
do not want that to happen
right it should be nice and it should be
measurable
it should be manageable so replication i
cannot emphasize enough
it's definitely worth the was for the
solution architects the enterprise
architects and rethink it
and try to get a grasp around like no
more uncontrolled port holes
to the cloud right if there is an outage
if the network
is running into contention what kind of
insights do you have on this is there a
way to measure who's running that
workload
the manageable like outages how do you
manage outages
something to think about and keep a
close eye on the network bandwidth
if app development team a is
using sales history right or if they're
moving sales industry to the public
cloud
unless you have a good replication
strategy the team b
and c will never know that the same
information that they're looking for
it's only on the public cloud right
versus them again pulling the same
information
through the wire and uh
again when you think about the
replication tool think about a good
audio solution on the cloud and use that
right you can pretty much start creating
that build on that story
from there you can think about the
different heterogeneous rdbms solutions
like perhaps
also land those events into kafka queue
or
build apis through it and then so on
in our case we do have uh our
application databases are
running on oracle db and i talked about
the
rich mckeeson history so for this
specific
uh version of the one we have on the
slide
it's almost around 20 years old and
more than often the implementation
reflects upon the skill sets
right that that were on the team at that
point in time
so this specific application database is
running low latency calls as app
databases should
but non-business arts it's also extended
to be doing
uh batch processing right because that
team had oracle talent
so they ended up doing etl batch work
non-business hours
and this is not uncommon so when we were
thinking about
uh what's the ideal path solution to
move away from oracle because we are
running capacity
we found the ideal candidate to be mysql
but again we we went with postgresql
for the reasons i'll talk about in the
few next slides
but uh good information out there for
folks who are in the same
boat uh multiple conversion utilities
available
like mig visor or r2pg you also have a
gcp heterogeneous tools product team you
can
interview them and see if they can do
something to ease that migration for you
so my sequel i talked about his ideal
candidate for appdbs it it is
thread-based
right and it's better for low-latency
connections and it can support many
connections and that's what we see
happening with oracle databases
at the same time you have a lot more
success stories
of folks having moved from oracle to
postgres
so that's one of the that this aspect
right of the
many success stories uh this was this
fade in heavily for our decision
the other specific right the utilization
of
sequences few of our apps use sequences
on oracle we use triggers heavily
which are also supported on postgresql
and
we are heavy into materialized views
i do not judge this is just how it
exists right just a messenger here
and we do use oracle partitioning uh our
success criteria was also we do not have
like get it done with what you have so
more with less the goal was to make
minimal changes to the java app code
and minimum changes to the current
legacy application i would call legacy
now
and still move away from oracle given
those
guard rails osgrace is the best
candidate that we ended up picking
we have been a elastic show up for
almost five years we started on-prem
we were running capacity so we ended up
moving our elastic
cache databases to azure azure at the
time
did not have a pass service which could
support aggregate functions
which we heavily utilized like group
buys and so on so we had to fall back
into the is set up
now is natively for folks who have built
right the infrastructure as a service
it's not a
not a walk in the park right it's not an
easy thing to do and
what further complicates is the bigger
these cache databases
become the more are the failure points
right the higher is the risk matrix
uh currently we are facing on our is
stack the bigger
disks which are attached to these cache
databases need encryption and these
encryption processes
may run for two to three days so that's
our biggest failure point right that
might hit our slas
so we had been meaning to get out of is
and uh very recently as of three months
back
right elastic cloud they announced uh ga
for hipaa compliance
that's that's excellent we need hipaa
for all the workloads we put in fly
on the cloud and uh there's also
aggregate function support
where are we on this journey we did
check out our application compatibility
on the elastic cloud elastic service and
we're also looking into the
gcp credits that we can flow through the
elastic cloud instance
this is an interesting concept
right as a if you have an oracle
database and the ask is to move away
from oracle database
the first thought goes into
finding another database on the cloud so
we were no different
we have an information warehouse just
like many other folks do actually every
shop has an information warehouse
so if you reflect upon what what was the
reason why that information warehouse
came into existence right we pretty much
reflected upon ourselves
and uh it had to be a fact-based quest
because i reported to data analytics so
the data has to back it up right for any
reasoning
and we trended each and every pattern
what are the workloads running in the
information warehouse
we came to the conclusion that there
were only a handful of
data analysts who were used using that
database to
run queries and these are the guys who
are connecting through accessdb and so
on so essentially what they're doing is
just pulling information out
and if that's what they're doing and not
running queries why do you need a
database
so when we thought about that concept
one of our
vendors right in betas they have a
utility called automated
workload transformation what does the
tool do
you put in different flavors of software
on the left hand side
and auto magically on the other side a
different version comes out
in our case we had pl sql procedures we
had c plus plus
applications built over last 20 plus
years
and we had uwp oracle warehouse builder
which is also end of life oracle etl
tool
so we push all that application on the
left hand side as input to the workload
transformation
and we like open source is our auto
and pass so we wanted it to be converted
into a data proc
friendly version so in our case we
converted that code to pi spark
and on that little black screen very
hard to interpret
this is a 14 000 lines of code the way
the
workflow transformation works is it
comments the original application code
and right underneath it's going to put
the converted
block right so it's easy to diagnose
so just the takeaway would be just
because you have a
database application it doesn't have to
be solved from for database to database
there could be other ways to
solve it without a db
we have had different hadoop
flavors over the years i started out
with hortonworks
and before hortonworks and cloud data
combined
but uh more recently we shut down our
on-prem
cloud era cluster and removed
the artwork loads to convert to data
proc and
uh just going into the weeds here a
little bit we did work with our internal
cloud team and our network teams to open
up this cp
we utilized the disk utility
with an adobe framework to move data
from hdfs into the pockets
the gcs buckets the nice thing about
google cloud is by default storage is
encrypted
so you cut down that additional layer
saves a lot of time
not having to encrypt again the assets
that we
use again uh hipaa compliant or
metastore we do use mysql a small
instance and it's geo-replicated
for folks who do not know why metastore
is being called out
the clusters as such are right this
compute is expensive and storage is
cheap on public cloud
so the goal should be to minimize the
utilization of compute if you're not
using it
then why is it running 24 7
that's called transient cluster that we
destroy it
when they're not being used so our data
probe clusters they come into
being for one or two hours they run the
workload
and then they vanish and where do they
save the table structures and all that
good stuff it's in the meta store
that's what it's doing our transiency is
super important
uh keep an eye on the cost i've been
doing cloud for
almost five years here so i can tell the
difference between the
the old legacy way of cutting a big
check and
after towards the end of five year life
cycle
your sla start taking a hit right but
you
there's only so much you can do you
never lose cost because your hardware
can only support that much right your
apps might take a hit
but you're not spending extra whereas on
the cloud
you very quickly as your workload and
your data increases
you might be paying through the lows
it's imperative keep your eyes on the
cost optimized
when we audit our cost on a monthly
basis
and and also share the insights with our
senior leadership on how much are we
spending
and what applications are chewing up
that cost
that's great to hear and show them as
you can see medicine
addressed several aspirational goals
here they are
uh what they wanted to move into open
source adoption and that they want to
modernize their analytics implement
visualization stack
and more importantly modernize the skill
set of the organization
and adapt and adopted trends enterprises
increasingly
want to adopt open source and move away
from licensed software
wherever possible as the business grows
and more and more data is made available
and the need to modernize
analytics environment becomes
increasingly important
translating this information into
insightful visualizations
becomes unnecessary enterprises want to
adapt to meet these modernization
challenges
and it includes modernizing the skill
set as well
as enterprises evolve on cloud adoption
the focus is on
lean devops and control their ongoing
spend
and that was a wonderful story and show
and
thank you for walking us through your
highly informative and educative
data modernization journey it is uh
especially interesting to see how you
started this effort off to
integrate siloed enrolments within your
organization with safe methodology and
address some very complex challenges on
your replication uh on application
databases your cache databases
uh your information warehouse and also
the hardware end of life
there are some of the these are some of
the challenges that all the enterprises
face today
thank you once again and thank you very
much